what's going on kind of coffee today's
breeze big bridal shower day things that
started off to a crazy story forgot a
coffee and we have a Barbie cake in the
back which is kind of fragile so Jenna
be very very careful with your driving
I've never driven the minivan before I
think coffee cut the coffee guys bridal
shower it's okay I dress myself Lily you
look burned away I'll go the ER got hot
and I are on our way down this is
actually take two because I wasn't
reporting we may adhere it to the
destination it's time to start
decorating I'm a little bit concerned
about the helium tank open it up
I'm good open it up Barbie's getting
unboxed you should do the unboxing Jess
we are helium tank and we're gonna try
to blow up some balloons now
where's the balloons oh wait I need it I
flip that string how does it say in
there how does this work
I lost the other really shower free
obviously never thrown a bridal shower
before
Justine ordered pinata to breathe the
hen fry hashtag right to breathe
please how the winning and forget I hope
you're looking at me now from the corner
hey Briana and Ryan maybe 14 2006 to see
let me Lee get that shot going on Ivan
nice here too but it leaves a nice in
there it's sharp
so
I will be starring in your movie
Breanna's open all her presents and now
do you know what time is it Marie what
it is time for you to cut Barbie am i
cutting garvik you're cutting Barbie oh
I feel bad cutting her she needs to be
eaten
we need to get a nice giant picture and
Barbie first maybe you don't have to
hold him
that is heavy yeah there's a lot of cake
in there serious lumpectomy Express okay
little Jake picture first ring that's
great the question is who's gonna eat
Barbie's body hold on wait no well
there's not a cake in there yep give her
a nice soft chopper I think you cut her
like yeah you hit sometimes later I
thought her head bones they should
practice your wedding
Brian oh you're a wild layer all right
you're going so far but I'm get I'm just
slicing up my cutters I got to the leg I
got to the leg okay very stable yeah
make sure Mike Oliver no losing her
stabilize the cake I guess I seen the
shower I'm not even sure what I filmed
because it was just craziness trying to
film free and take pictures and all
kinds of stuff and Mady see hi and all
the flowers were so pretty
Dez made all of these and she even spray
painted like the vases and every time I
was an idea that's crazy she spray
painted to the inside silver should be
ready my family tomorrow so early flight
6 a.m. Jen like 6:00 a.m. 6:00 a.m.
flight